the symbol of the circle doctor ml
Fonfon says explained the circle or
sphere as a symbol of the self it
expresses the totality of the psyche in
all its aspects including the
relationship between man and the whole
of nature whether the symbol of the
circle appears in primitive Sun worship
or modern religion in myths or dreams in
the mandalas drawn by Tibetan monks in
the ground plans of cities or in the
spherical concepts of early astronomers
it always points to the single most
vital aspect of life its ultimate
wholeness an Indian creation myth
relates that the God Brahma standing on
a huge thousand petal Lotus turned his
eyes to the four points of the compass
this fourfold survey from the circle of
the Lotus was a kind of preliminary
orientation an indispensable taking of
bearings before he began his work of
creation a similar story is told of
Buddha at the moment of his birth a
lotus flower arose from the earth and he
stepped into it to gaze into the ten
directions of space the Lotus in this
case was a trade and Buddha also gazed
upward and downward making ten
directions this symbolic gesture of
survey was the most concise method of
showing that from the moment of his
birth the Buddha was a unique
personality predestined to receive
illumination his personality and his
further existence were given the imprint
of wholeness the spatial orientation
performed by Brahma and Buddha may be
regarded as symbolic of the human need
for psychic orientation the four
functions of consciousness described by
dr. Jung in part one thought feeling
intuition and sensation equipped man to
deal with the impressions of the world
he receives from within and without it
is by means of these functions that he
comprehends and assimilates his
experience it is by means of them that
he can respond Brahmas fourfold survey
of the universe symbolizes the necessary
integration of these four functions that
man must achieve in art the circle is
often a trade this expresses a risk
berkel overlapping of the four functions
of consciousness so that for further
intermediate functions come about for
instance thought colored by feeling or
intuition or feeling tending towards
sensation in the visual art of India and
the Far East the for or a trade circle
is the usual pattern of the religious
images that serve as instruments of
meditation in tibetan lama ism
especially richly figured mandalas play
an important part as a rule these
mandalas represent the cosmos and its
relation to divine powers but a great
many of the Eastern meditation figures
are purely geometrical in design these
are called yonkers aside from the circle
a very common Yantra motif is formed by
two interpenetrating triangles one point
upward the other point downward
traditionally this shape symbolizes the
union of Shiva and Shakti the male and
female divinities a subject that also
appears in sculpture in countless
variations in terms of psychological
symbolism it expresses the union of
opposites the union of the personal
temporal world of the ego with the non
personal timeless world of the non ego
ultimately this union is the fulfillment
and goal of all religions it is the
union of the soul with God the two
interpenetrating triangles have a
symbolic meaning similar to that of the
more common circular mandala they
represent the wholeness of the psyche or
self of which consciousness is just as
much a part as the unconscious
in both the triangle Yonkers and the
sculptural representations of the union
of Shiva and Shakti the emphasis lives
on a tension between the opposites hence
the marked erotic and emotional
character of many of them this dynamic
quality implies a process the creation
or coming into being of wholeness while
the for or a trade circle represents
wholeness as such as an existing entity
the abstract circle also figures in Zen
painting speaking of a picture entitled
the circle by the famous then priest
sungai another Zen master
right in the Zhen sect the circle
represents enlightenment
it symbolizes human perfection abstract
mandalas also appear in European
Christian art some of the most splendid
examples are the Rose windows of the
cathedrals these are representations of
the self of man transposed onto the
cosmic plane a cosmic mandala in the
shape of a shining white rose was
revealed to Dante in a vision we may
regard as mandalas the halos of Christ
and the Christian Saints and religious
paintings in many cases the halo of
Christ is alone
divided into four a significant allusion
to his sufferings as the son of man and
his death on the cross and at the same
time a symbol of his differentiated
wholeness on the walls of early
Romanesque churches abstract circular
figures can sometimes be seen they may
go back to pagan originals in
non-christian art such circles are
called Sun wheels they appear in rock
engravings that date back to the
Neolithic epochs before the wheel was
invented as young has pointed out the
term Sun wheel denotes only the external
aspect of the figure what really
mattered at all times was the experience
of an archetypal inner image which Stone
Age man rendered in his art as
faithfully as he depicted Bulls gazelles
or wild horses many pictorial mandalas
are to be found in Christian art for
example the rather rare picture of the
Virgin in the centre of a circular tree
which is the God symbol of the burning
bush the most widely current mandalas in
Christian art are those of Christ
surrounded by the four evangelists these
go back to the ancient Egyptian
representations of the god horus and his
four sons note the picture of the Virgin
in the center of a circular tree is the
central panel of the TWiT keep debris
solid on 1476 catapults all severe X on
Provence end of note in architecture the
mandala also plays an important part but
one that often passes unnoticed it forms
the ground
of both secular and sacred buildings in
nearly all civilizations it enters into
classical medieval and even modern town
planning's a classical example appears
in Plutarch's accounted the foundation
of Rome according to Plutarch Romulus
sent four builders from Etruria who
instructed him by secret usages and
written rules about all the ceremonies
to be observed in the same way as in the
mysteries first they dug around pit
where the Collegium or court of assembly
now stands and into this pit they
through symbolic offerings of the fruits
of the earth then each man took a small
piece of earth of the land from which he
came and these were all thrown into the
pit together the pit was given the name
of mundus which also meant two cosmos
around it
Romulus drew the boundary of the city in
a circle with a plough drawn by a bull
and a cow wherever a gate was planned
the ploughshare was taken out and the
plow carried over note examples of
sacred buildings with mandala ground
plans borobudur Java the Taj Mahal the
Omar mosque in Jerusalem secular
buildings castel del Monte built by the
holy roman emperor frederick ii 1194 to
1250 in Apulia end of note the city
founded in this solemn ceremony was
circular in shape yet the old and famous
description of Rome is ohrp's quadrat
the square city according to one theory
that attempts to reconcile this
contradiction the word quadratherm must
be understood to mean quadripartite that
is the circular City was divided into
four parts by two main arteries running
from north to south and west to east the
point of intersection coincided with the
Mundus mentioned by Plutarch according
to another theory the contradiction can
be understood only as a symbol namely as
a visual representation of the
mathematically insoluble problem of the
squaring of the circle which had greatly
preoccupied the Greeks and was to play
so great a part in alchemy
strangely enough before describing the
circle ceremony of the foundation of the
city by Romulus Plutarch also speaks of
Rome as Roma quod rata a square city for
him Rome was both a circle and a square
in each theory a true Mangal is involved
and that links up with Plutarch
statement that the foundation of the
city was taught by the Etruscans as in
the mysteries as a secret right it was
more than a mere outward form by its
Mundell a ground plan the city with its
inhabitants is exalted above the purely
secular realm this is further emphasized
by the fact that the city has a center
the Mundus which established the city's
relationship to the other realm the
abode of the ancestral spirits the
mundis was covered by a great stone
called the soul stone on certain days
the stone was removed and then it was
said the spirits of the Dead rose from
the shaft a number of medieval cities
were founded on the ground plan of a
mandala and were surrounded by an
approximately circular wall in such a
city as in Rome two main arteries
divided it into quarters and led to the
four gates the church or Cathedral stood
at the point of intersection of these
arteries the inspiration of the medieval
city with its quarters was the heavenly
Jerusalem in the book of Revelation
which had a square grand plan and walls
with three times four gates but
Jerusalem had no temple at its center
for God's immediate presence was the
center of us the Mundell aground plan
for a city is by no means outmoded a
modern example is the city of Washington
DC whether in classical or in primitive
foundations the mandala ground plan was
never dictated by considerations of
aesthetics or economics it was a
transformation of the city into an
ordered cosmos a sacred place bound by
its center to the Otherworld and this
transformation accorded with the vital
feelings and needs of religious man
every building sacred or secular that
has a Mundell a ground plan is the
projection of an archetypal image from
within the human unconscious onto the
outer world
the city the fortress and the temple
become symbols of psychic wholeness and
in this way exercise a specific
influence on the human being who enters
or lives in the place it need hardly be
emphasized that even in architecture the
projection of the psychic content was a
purely unconscious process such things
cannot be thought up dr. Jung has
written but must grow again from the
Forgotten depths if they are to express
the deepest insights of consciousness
and the loftiest intuitions of the
Spirit
thus amalgamating the uniqueness of
present-day consciousness with the
age-old past of humanity the central
symbol of Christian art is not the
mandala but the cross or crucifix up to
Carolingian times the equilateral or
Greek cross was the usual form and
therefore the mandala was indirectly
implied but in the course of time the
center moved upward until the cross took
on the Latin form with the stake and the
cross beam that is customary today this
development is important because it
corresponds to the inward development of
Christianity up to the high middle ages
in simple terms it symbolized the
tendency to remove the center of man and
his faith from the earth and to elevate
it into the spiritual sphere this
tendency sprang from the desire to put
into action Christ saying my kingdom is
not of this world
earthly life the world and the body were
therefore forces that had to be overcome
medieval man's hopes were thus directed
to the beyond for it was only from
paradise that the promise of fulfillment
beckoned this endeavor reached its
climax in the Middle Ages and in
medieval mysticism the hopes of the
beyond found expression not only in the
raising of the center of the cross it
can also be seen in the increasing
height of the Gothic cathedrals which
seemed to set the laws of gravity at
defiance there cruciform ground plan is
that of the elongated Latin cross though
the baptistry is with the front in the
center have a true mandala ground plan
with the dawning of the Renaissance a
revolutionary change began to occur in
man's conception of the world the upward
move
which reached its climax in the late
Middle Ages went into reverse man turned
back to the earth he rediscovered the
beauties of nature and the body made the
first circumnavigation of the globe and
proved the world to be a sphere the laws
of mechanics and causality became the
foundations of science the world of
religious feeling of the irrational and
of mysticism which had played so great a
part in medieval times was more and more
submerged by the triumphs of logical
thought similarly art became more
realistic and sensuous it broke away
from the religious subjects of the
Middle Ages and embraced the whole
visible world it was overwhelmed by the
manifold miss of the earth by its
splendor and horror and became what
gothic art had been before it a true
symbol of the spirit of the age
thus it can hardly be regarded as
accidental that a change also came over
ecclesiastical building in contrast to
the soaring gothic cathedrals there were
more circular ground plans the circle
replaced the Latin cross this change in
form however and this is the important
point for the history of symbolism must
be attributed to aesthetic and not to
religious causes that is the only
possible explanation for the fact that
the center of these rom searches the
truly holy place is empty and that the
altar stands in a recess in a wall away
from the center for that reason the plan
cannot be described as a true mandalas
an important exception is st. Peter's in
Rome which was built to the plans of
Bramante and Michelangelo here the altar
stands in the center one is tempted
however to attribute this exception to
the genius of the architects for great
genius is always both of and beyond its
time in spite of the far-reaching
changes in art philosophy and science
brought about by the Renaissance the
central symbol of Christianity remained
unchanged Christ was still represented
on the Latin cross as he is today that
meant that the center of religious man
remained anchored on a higher more
spiritual plane than that of earthly man
who had turned back to nature thus a
rift arose between man's traditional
Christianity and
rational or intellectual mind since that
time these two sides of modern man have
never been brought together in the
course of the centuries with man's
growing insight into nature and its laws
this division has gradually grown wider
and it still splits the psyche of the
Western Christian in the 20th century of
course the brief historical summary
given here has been oversimplified
moreover it omits the secret religious
movements within Christianity that took
account in their beliefs of what was
usually ignored by most Christians the
question of evil the chthonic or earthly
spirit such movements were always in a
minority and seldom had any very visible
influence but in their way they
fulfilled the important role of a
contrapuntal accompaniment to Christian
spirituality among the many sects and
movements that arose about AD 1,000 the
alchemists played a very important part
they exalted the mysteries of matter and
set them alongside those of the heavenly
spirit of Christianity what they thought
was a wholeness of man encompassing mind
and body and they invented a thousand
names and symbols for it one of their
central symbols was the quadrature
Cooley the squaring of the circle which
is no more than the true mandala the
alchemists not only recorded their work
in their writings they created a wealth
of pictures of their dreams and visions
symbolic pictures that are still as
profound as they are baffling they were
inspired by the dark side of nature evil
the dream the spirit of Earth the mode
of expression was always fabulous
dreamlike and unreal in both word and
picture the great 15th century Flemish
painter Hieronymus Bosch may be regarded
as the most important representative of
this kind of imaginative art but at the
same time more typical Renaissance
painters working in the full light of
day so to speak we're producing the most
splendid works of sensuous art their
fascination with earth and nature went
so deep that it practically determined
the development of visual art for the
next five centuries the last great
representatives of sensuous art the art
of the
moment of light and air where the
nineteenth-century Impressionists we may
here discriminate between two radically
different modes of artistic
representation many attempts have been
made to define their characteristics
recently herbert toon whose work on the
cave paintings I have already mentioned
has tried to draw a distinction between
what he calls the imaginative and the
sensory style the sensory style
generally depicts a direct reproduction
of nature or of the picture subject the
imaginative on the other hand presents a
fantasy or experience of the artist in
an unrealistic even dreamlike and
sometimes abstract manner Kings two
conceptions seem so simple and so clear
that I am glad to make use of them the
first beginnings of imaginative art go
back very far in history in the
Mediterranean Basin it's efflorescence
dates from the third millennium BC it
has only recently been realized that
these ancient works of art are not the
results of incompetence or ignorant they
are modes of expression of a perfectly
definite religious and spiritual emotion
and they have a special appeal today for
during the last half century art has
been passing once more through a phase
that can be described by the term
imaginative today the geometrical or
abstract symbol of the circle has again
come to play a considerable role in
painting but with few exceptions the
traditional mode of representation has
undergone a characteristic
transformation that corresponds to the
dilemma of modern man's existence the
circle is no longer a single meaningful
figure that embraces a whole world and
dominates the picture sometimes the
artist has taken it out of its dominant
position replacing it by a loosely
organized group of circles sometimes the
plain of the circle is asymmetrical an
example of the asymmetrical circular
plain may be seen in the famous Sun
discs of the French painter Albert de
Launay a painting by the modern English
painter Siri Richards now in dr. Young's
collection contains an entirely
asymmetrical circular plain while far to
the left there
is a very much smaller and empty circle
in the French painter avi Matisse is
still life with Vaz of nasturtiums the
focus of vision is a green sphere on a
slanting black beam which seems to
gather into itself the manifold circles
of the nasturtiums eaves the sphere
overlaps a rectangular figure the top
left-hand corner of which is folded over
even the artistic perfection of the
painting it is easy to forget that in
the past these two abstract figures the
circle and the square would have been
united and would have expressed a world
of thoughts and feelings but anyone who
does remember and raises the question of
meaning will find food for thought the
two figures that from the beginning of
time have formed a whole are in this
painting torn apart or incoherently
related yet both are there and are
touching each other in a picture painted
by the Russian born artist Vasily
Kandinsky there is a loose assembly of
colored balls or circles that seem to be
drifting like soap bubbles they too are
tenuously connected with a background of
one large rectangle with too small
almost square rectangles contained in it
in another picture which he called a few
circles a dark cloud or is it a swooping
bird again there is a loosely arranged
group of bright balls or circles circles
often appear in unexpected connections
in the mysterious compositions of the
British artist Paul Nash in the primeval
solitude of his landscape event on the
downs a ball lies in the right
foreground though it is apparently a
tennis ball the design on its surface
forms the tie key to the Chinese symbol
of eternity thus it opens up a new
dimension in the loneliness of the
landscape something similar happens in
Nash's landscape from a dream balls are
rolling out of sight in an infinitely
wide mirrored landscape with a huge Sun
visible on the horizon another ball lies
in the foreground in front of the
roughly square mirror in his drawing
limits of understanding the Swiss artist
Powell
Cley places the simple figure of a
sphere or a circle above a complex
structure of ladders and lines dr. Young
has pointed out that a true symbol
appears only when there is a need to
express what thought cannot think or
what is only divined or felt that is the
purpose of clays simple figure at the
limits of understanding it is important
to note that the square or groups of
rectangles and squares or rectangles and
rhomboids have appeared in modern art
just as often as the circle the master
of harmonious indeed musical
compositions with squares is the
dutch-born artist Piet Mondrian as a
rule there is no actual center in any of
his pictures if they form an ordered
hole in their own strict almost
aesthetic fashion still more common are
paintings by other artists with
irregular quaternary compositions or
numerous rectangles combined in more or
less loose groups the circle is a symbol
of the psyche even Plato described the
psyche as a sphere the square and often
the rectangle is a symbol of earthbound
matter of the body and reality in most
modern art the connection between these
two primary forms is either non-existent
or loose and casual their separation is
another symbolic expression of the
psychic state of 20th century man his
soul has lost its roots and he is
threatened by dissociation even in the
world situation of today as dr. Jung
pointed out in his opening chapter this
split has become evident the western and
eastern halves of the earth are
separated by an iron curtain but the
frequency with which the square and the
circle appear must not be overlooked
there seems to be an uninterrupted
psychic urge to bring into consciousness
the basic factors of life that they
symbolize also in certain abstract
pictures of our time which merely
represent a colored structure or a kind
of primal matter these forms
occasionally appear as if they were
germs of new growth the symbol of the
circle has played a curious part in a
very different phenomenon of the life of
our day
and occasionally still does so in the
last years of the Second World War there
arose the visionary rumor of round
flying bodies that became known as
flying saucers or UFOs unidentified
flying objects Young has explained the
UFOs as a projection of a psychic
content of wholeness that has at all
times been symbolized by the circle in
other words this visionary rumor as can
also be seen in many dreams of our time
is an attempt by the unconscious
collective psyche to heal the split in
our apocalyptic age by means of the
symbol of the circle